buenos días pues la lectura que muchos
hacen es el efecto pandemia que afectó
bastante a esta participación porque
muchas personas tuvieron por ejemplo
problemas en el padrón estaban
registradas en los lugares de donde
proceden o donde viven y durante la
pandemia no se permitieron los viajes lo
que habría impedido que muchos de ellos
pudieran cambiar el padrón o se dieran
cuenta de poder hacerlo a tiempo también
había muchas personas que tenían miedo
de salir a la calle por eso la lectura
que hacen los analistas en este momento
es que a pesar de la pandemia la
participación fue como se decía en el
reportaje histórica una de las mayores
desde que el voto es voluntario y
también hay trascendidos de que podría
ser una de las participaciones más
significativas hay que revisar ahora
todos los datos históricos sin embargo
en la lectura que se hace desde chile
donde la sociedad ha estado más viendo
está afectada en cuestiones políticas el
hecho de que más de 50% de los chiles no
salían a la calle a votar se le de una
forma positiva
patricia la constitución será redactada
por
yo de una convención constitucional
explicamos esto qué significa y cuáles
son los pasos a seguir a partir de ahora
para obtener esta constitución y
aprobarla también
la convención constitucional era una de
las opciones que estaban en la boleta y
significa que los 155 personas
encargadas de redactar esa constitución
serán totalmente elegidas por el pueblo
frente a la otra opción que proponía que
fuera una mitad de políticos y otra
mitad de personas de la calle esto es
muy importante también porque por
primera vez será una constitución
paritaria en uno de los primeros casos
en el mundo en el que el 50% de las
mujeres participarán a la hora de
escribir la constitución y podrán querer
dejar ahí reflejados sus intereses sus
propuestas su forma de ver las cosas lo
que puede abre un proceso muy
interesante son ahora se abra ahora el
proceso para proponer a estas personas
ochocientos cincuenta y cinco candidatos
hasta el mes de abril donde habrá unas
nuevas elecciones para seleccionarlos y
a partir de ahí un plazo de entre nueve
meses que puede ser prorrogable para
redactar esta nueva carta magna que
sentará unos nuevos cimientos en la
sociedad chilena